ici à la limite entre neuilly et
levallois perret l'établissement les
bords de seine est l'un des plus chers
de france en moyenne par mois un
résident doit débourser entre 7000 et
15000 euros pourtant à l'intérieur la
vie pour les personnes âgées est bien
loin d'être idyllique
maltraitance négligence rationnement
dans son enquête le journaliste victor
castanet dénonce les conditions de vie
des résidents de ces ehpad orpea des
révélations qui se base sur près de 250
entretien avec le personnel soignant
nous étions rationnés c'était trois
couches par jour maximum peu importe que
les résidents soient malades qu'il y ait
une gastro qu'il y ait une épidémie des
soignants raconte qu'il se trouvait
obligé de subtiliser en catimini des
produits dans les réserves de
l'établissement pour nourrir les
résidents des personnes âgées également
parfois laissé sans soins pendant
plusieurs jours en cause notamment le
manque de personnel un ou deux soignants
pour quatorze résidents le jour et
seulement 3 % 25 lits la nuit quand on
est en sous-effectif on ne peut pas
donner le temps qu'il faut aux patients
je ne peux pas lui donner sa douche tout
seul en revanche il peut arriver des
week-ends où ils font en sorte qu'il y
ait toujours des personnes
supplémentaires pour plaire aux familles
orpea génère des milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires par an dans le même
temps le groupe reçoit des dotations
publiques entre 1 et 2 millions d'euros
par an et par établissement au profit
des résidents un argent dont il n'y a
pas de traces affirme le journaliste
une patiente couverte de bleus un autre
enfermé dans sa chambre
la réalité que décrit victor castanet ne
passe pas inaperçu et parvient même
jusqu'aux oreilles du gouvernement il
s'est saisi de la fère et demande aux
gestionnaires de répondre à ces
accusations
j'ai demandé à la ministre en charge de
l'autonomie de saisir immédiatement le
groupe orpea de manière à ce que des
réponses puisse être apportée à la
lumière de ces conclusions je verrai
s'il ya lieu de diligenter une enquête
de l'inspection générale
orpea de son côté nie en bloc
se dit néanmoins ouvert à la discussion
nous n'avons rien à cacher se défend le
directeur de la filiale française nous
contestons formellement l'ensemble de
ces accusations que nous considérons
comme mensongères outrageante et
préjudiciable orpea ses dirigeants et
ses collaborateurs ont toujours placé
depuis 30 ans le bien-être des résidents
l'accompagnement des équipes et
l'éthique professionnelle au coeur des
critères de leur action et du
développement de l'entreprise depuis
jeudi une inspection est menée par l'
agence régionale de santé dans
l'établissement du groupe le directeur
général lui est convoqué le 1er février
par la ministre déléguée en charge de
l'autonomie et ce n'est pas la première
affaire qui touche le secteur des
maisons de retraites ces dernières
années emmanuel macron face à l'ensemble
de ces dysfonctionnements avaient
annoncé en 2019 un plan d'investissement
pour les ehpad un projet de loi intitulé
grand âge qui a finalement été abandonné
en septembre dernier